I think breaking news just moments ago
Victoria tun Singh she is the attorney
for the uranium one informant is
confirming to this show tonight that in
fact the FBI is investigating the
Clinton Foundation and meanwhile
Democrats are doing everything they can
do to try and discredit remember the
informant they are selectively leaking
information to their friends and the
left-wing media now we also have other
breaking news from the Attorney General
Jeff Sessions he was on last night with
our own shannon bream and he said that
he is seriously now considering
appointing a second special counsel tick
tock watch this well I have great
respect from mr. Gowdy and chairman
Goodlatte and we're going to consider
seriously their recommendations I have
appointed in person outside of
Washington many years in the Department
of Justice to look at all the
allegations that the House Judiciary
Committee members sent to us and we're
conducting that investigation also am
well aware that we have a responsibility
to ensure the integrity of the FISA
process we're not afraid to look at that
this is huge news joining us with
reaction
he is the chief counsel for the American
Center for Law and Justice and the
attorney to the President of the United
States Jay Sekulow I want to go back Jay
if I may over these comments he said
that in this interview last night I've
appointed a person outside of Washington
many years at the Department of Justice
looking at the allegations that the
House Judiciary Committee members sent
us and we are conducting that
investigation and he stated he is well
aware we have responsibility to ensure
the integrity of the FISA process this
is a huge development it is Shaun and I
think the important part to focus on on
here is that the Attorney General said
he's already appointed someone with a
lot of experience outside of Washington
DC but a lot of experience within the
Department of Justice who is already
conducting an investigation that
investigation in all probability is a
determination being reviewed as to
whether in fact that special counsel as
has been requested by the chairman of
the Judiciary Committee has been called
for by members of the United States
Senate had been called for by trey Gowdy
you and I have been talking about it for
a long time
so what's happened right now is it looks
like the Department of Justice has
appointed someone with a lot of
experience to make the determination or
at least make advice as the
determination as to whether a special
counsel should be appointed for this
precise situation especially as it
relates to the FISA abuse which is such
a big scenario Jay my sources at the
Department of Justice they've been very
clear that in their view I disagree with
that I think we have there is enough
evidence that we know now that would
warn and justify a special counsel the
feeling has been we got away for the IG
report to come out then of course the
DOJ attorneys have to look at it then
they would consider the appointment of a
special counsel
it seems unbeknownst to all of us Jeff
Sessions was doing a lot more than any
of us knew yeah and you know we talked
about that before weird the public
doesn't always know what the Department
of Justice is doing internally remember
according to the regulations here the
Department of Justice has a process that
they go through in reviewing as to
whether a special counsel should be
appointed now you've got to have an
issue of criminality you have to have an
issue of conflict of interest I think in
both of those situations as it relates
to the FISA investigation it warrants a
special counsel and it appears that with
Jeff Sessions the Attorney General is
done has started that process of
internal review that by the way could
dual track with the inspector general
they're not mutually exclusive it's not
one or the other but the courts the
special counsel has a deeper ability to
talk to witnesses outside of the
existing Department of Justice personnel
which is one of the limitations imposed
on an Inspector General so I think this
is significant I think it's significant
for the rule of law and especially when
you're talking about a FISA situation
which was based on a unverified or a
salacious in the words of James Comey
dossier that that dossier information
was leaked to the press that the
individual Christopher Steele who put
that dossier together was involved with
Bruce or the number four at the
Department of Justice wife as far as
working for she was working for fusion
GPS I mean you start putting these
together and then course he ultimately
gets fired chrissteele because he leaked
the information to the press now did
they tell that to the court in the FISA
warrant I suspect not
again this goes to the point that you
have a FISA courts are very serious
foreign intelligence surveillance act
place to protect the American people and
that's what this special counsel needs
to be looking at the FISA law is very
clear
FBI protocols are very clear that they
have a legal moral ethical even there by
their own standards obligation to verify
and corroborate any materials at a
simple four or five as a court it seems
to me there are a lot of issues in play
here an exoneration before an
investigation months before that is
unheard of secondly if you have the
witnesses were given Shawn witnesses
were given immunity in that situation
computers
wait a minute witnesses weren't even
interviewed I mean as far as when that
report when the draft of the report that
was put together then remember this
Andrew McCabe said that they would not
have you been sought the FISA warrant
without the Christopher Steele dossier
and then think about this James Comey
goes to the president-elect of the
United States and tells the
president-elect of the United States
that there's dossiers out there but it's
salacious and unverified meanwhile
here's a question why is it to obtain a
FISA warrant all right so that warrant
was renewed yeah but but this is the
point the FISA warrant it was unverified
they didn't follow the FISA law they
didn't file the FBI protocols James
Comey allowed it to happen
they don't they never told the judge
that it was bought and paid for by
Hillary Clinton that's lying by omission
and then he tells Donald Trump just
before he's inaugurated or salacious and
I'm verified but they're telling a court
in October they're putting all the faith
and credibility of their department on
this yeah but also remember this they
also renewed it was it the day before
the inauguration based on the same
information so what you have here is the
reason we just stated the case for why a
special counsel should be appointed and
I believe that's what's going to happen
all right Jay Sekulow thank you for so
much for joining us we appreciate